Speaker 3: Hi. I was just kind of wondering
what you think about what's going to happen
in midterm elections? I mean, I'm not looking too
much at like polls at this point, but just from my
perception, I feel like Democrats are getting a
lot less popular. A lot of people, you know, are
blaming Biden for the gas bill or the gas prices.
And I just feel like if they don't do anything
about it, they're going to stay very unpopular. I
was wondering if you thought that they were either
aware of it or like what you would recommend.
Speaker 1: So I think Democrats are aware
of it. So so there's two sides to
this. Austin, the first part of it is
historically, and if you can do something to
turn off the discord blinks, that would be
really great. I don't know if you're using push to
talk or if you haven't silence notifications, but
I would love your help with that. So on the one
hand, for historical reasons, typically when a
party wins the White House, then the next midterms
aren't good for them. So like historically
speaking, Democrats should should lose at least
control of the House or Senate in November.
On the other hand, we have this situation where
in 2016 and 2020 you had a lot of Trumpists
voting who never voted before Trump. They only
got involved in politics because of Trump. And
it remains an open question whether there is going
to be a sort of a disappearance of many of those
individuals, and they're not even going to vote
in November. The other question is we know COVID
has killed more Republicans than Democrats. To
what effect will the Partizan death gap of COVID
affect Republicans, so Democrats should be losing?
Historically, Joe Biden is also getting blamed
for stuff that's not his fault, like gas prices.
That's that those are not good things for them.
But I think it's such a unique midterm that
it remains to be seen. I don't really have
a prediction.
Speaker 3:
Yeah. Do you think that though, like certain parts
like, I don't know, do you think, do you see kind
of the new like decriminalization of marijuana
bill is like something that they might be
putting forth to kind of reclaim some popularity
because I just feel like from the perspective,
like they have not really gotten anything done
with like the infrastructure bill being gutted
and they're not really doing anything popular
like as of right now or making an effort to.
Speaker 1: I think that time is quite short
and it would be really great for Democrats if
they want to do well to try to get something
else major done. But to be perfectly frank,
it's not seeming to me like they're they're going
to be able to do it. So they're going to have to
run on convincing people based on what's already
happened. And that's quite frankly, it seems like
that's going to be a difficult thing to do.
Speaker 3: Yeah, I kind of just wish they
had more control over, you know, getting policies
that are popular, but obviously there's a lot of,
I guess, red tape within the party.
Speaker 1: Yeah, and there's also
a limited amount of political
capital. The one thing I will say is
I don't really think Joe Biden has much of an
interest in doing student loan forgiveness,
but he still could look at doing something
like that. And maybe the new moratorium on
payments until August is him saying, Well, maybe
in August, I'll do some student loan forgiveness,
which will help us in November. That was Pat's
idea on a recent bonus show. I don't know. I don't
know, but I think it's an interesting question.
Speaker 3: Yeah. Well, thank you for your time,
I definitely agree that Biden should
be doing some kind of like emergency
kind of catch up. I feel like you're just catching
a lot of flak for inflation and gas. And like,
I obviously don't have like any like concrete
evidence on this. But just from what I've seen
living in, like Florida, I'm at the University of
Florida, but I'm from Miami. Just a lot of like A.
Biden sentiment. Let's go, Brandon is everywhere.
Yeah. I'm just a little worried for the future.
Speaker 1: You're right to be worried.
Austin, thank you so much for the call